Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. You knew, Emperor of India Shah Jahan, that life, youth, wealth, renown all float away down the stream of time. Your only dream was to preserve forever your heart's pain. The harsh thunder of imperial power would fade into sleep like a sunset's crimson splendor but it was your hope that at least a single eternally heaved sigh would stay to grieve the sky though emeralds rubies pearls are all but as the glitter of time in the form of this white and gleaming Taj Mahal." So that, Dominic, was Rabindranath Tagore, the great Bengali writer,
感谢您收听《历史就是如此》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。“印度皇帝沙贾汗，你深知生命、青春、财富、名望，这一切都随时间之流漂逝。你唯一的梦想，就是永远留住你心中的伤痛。帝国权力的严酷雷鸣，终将如日落时那抹绯红的辉煌般归于沉寂，但你希望至少能留下一声永恒的叹息，去哀悼那片天空，尽管绿宝石、红宝石、珍珠，在这座洁白闪耀的泰姬陵面前，不过是时间的浮华。”多米尼克，刚才那段话出自伟大的孟加拉作家拉宾德拉纳特·泰戈尔，
the first non-European, I think, to win the Nobel Prize for literature, writing about one of the world's most famous buildings, the Taj Mahal. I guess it could be a candidate of the world's most famous buildings, the Taj Mahal. And I guess it could be a candidate for the world's most famous building. Definitely the world's most romantic building. Yeah. Built for love. It's sort of seen as a symbol, isn't it, of India, of romance, and of exoticism in the West, don't you think?
我想他是第一位获得诺贝尔文学奖的非欧洲人，他笔下描写的是世界上最著名的建筑之一——泰姬陵。我想它或许能成为世界上最著名建筑的候选者。当然，它绝对是世界上最浪漫的建筑。没错，它是为爱而建的。在西方人眼中，它似乎被视为印度、浪漫和异国情调的象征，你不觉得吗？
So the image of the Taj Mahal is one that newspaper travel supplement editors will always reach for when they're telling you about the image of the taj mahal is one that uh newspaper travel supplement editors will always reach for when they're telling you about the trip of a lifetime or you know stretching your horizons or it's the taj mahal that is always the building that is featured at the center of that i mean it is also very much a kind of shorthand for devotion marital love that kind of thing you know the famous person who utilized it to that effect was Princess Diana, who was it, in 1992, when she sat directly in front of it on her own without Prince Charles, as he then was, kind of making a very public statement. So it is absolutely a building that carries an entire freight of meaning, significations, Yeah. And as you say, a symbol of India abroad, but also that it's a great Muslim building built
所以，泰姬陵的形象总是报纸旅游副刊编辑在向你介绍一生难得的旅行，或者说拓宽视野时会用到的素材。泰姬陵总是那个出现在画面中心的建筑。我的意思是，它在很大程度上也是一种关于奉献、婚姻爱情之类的速记符号。你知道，最著名的利用这一点的人是戴安娜王妃。那是1992年，当她独自一人坐在泰姬陵前，没有当时还是王储的查尔斯王子陪伴时，她做出了一种非常公开的姿态。所以，这绝对是一座承载了全部意义和内涵的建筑。没错。正如你所说，它是印度在海外的象征，但它同时也是一座伟大的穆斯林建筑，由
by Muslim emperors. And so in contemporary India, not entirely uncontroversial. So we thought it would be a kind of wonderful theme for an episode of The Rest is History. We have the perfect person to guide us to the origins of the Taj, how it came to be built, history after its building. That is Dr. Mehreen Chida Razvi, who is the in-house editor for the Khalili Collection of Islamic Art, world expert on the art and architecture of the period of the emperors who built it, the Mughals. Mary, welcome to the show. Thank you so much for joining us. Yeah, it's my absolute pleasure. And what does the Taj mean to you?
穆斯林皇帝建造。因此，在当代印度，它并非完全没有争议。所以我们认为，这对于《历史就是如此》的一期节目来说，是一个非常棒的主题。我们请到了最合适的人选来引导我们了解泰姬陵的起源、它是如何建成的，以及它建成后的历史。她就是梅琳·奇达·拉兹维博士，她是哈利利伊斯兰艺术收藏馆的内部编辑，也是建造泰姬陵的莫卧儿王朝时期艺术与建筑的世界级专家。梅琳，欢迎来到节目。非常感谢你能加入我们。是的，这是我的荣幸。那么，泰姬陵对你来说意味着什么？
To me, the Taj Mahal, it is an absolutely iconic building. And it, for me, stands as a historical reminder of a period of history where the syncretic nature of the Mughal Empire and the Mughal court was very much on display. And it speaks to that. And as you mentioned, there are some contemporary issues surrounding it. So it stands as that reminder to a time where things might have been a little bit better than they are right now. So give us a bit of context. Tom said that Taj Mahal dates from the era of the Mughal emperors. So for those of our listeners who are not incredibly familiar with Indian history, who are the Mughals?
对我而言，泰姬陵是一座绝对标志性的建筑。它对我来说，是一个历史的提醒，提醒人们那个时期莫卧儿帝国和莫卧儿宫廷的融合性质得到了充分的展现。它诉说着这一切。正如你提到的，围绕它存在一些当代问题。所以它作为一个提醒，让人回想起那个事物可能比现在稍微好一点的时代。那么，请给我们提供一些背景信息。汤姆说泰姬陵源于莫卧儿皇帝时代。所以，对于那些对印度历史不太熟悉的听众，莫卧儿人是谁？
Where do they come from? What do they mean? And whereabouts are we in history? So the Mughal dynasty lasts from 1526 to 1858. As you mentioned, this is a series of Muslim kings ruling over the region of South Asia. They are of a Mongol line, and they come from, in this period, Central Asia.
他们从哪里来？他们代表什么？我们现在处于历史的哪个阶段？莫卧儿王朝从1526年持续到1858年。正如你提到的，这是一系列统治南亚地区的穆斯林君主。他们是蒙古血统，在这一时期，他们来自中亚。
So Babur, the founder of the Mughal dynasty, he is the ruler of a principality, the principality of Ferghana. The Ferghana Valley is primarily located in today's Uzbekistan. And so he's one of a series of Timurid princelings, so the great empire of Timur. His descendants are all vying for power in the Central Asian region. And Babur comes out of Thirghana with the idea of trying to reestablish Timur's great empire. But he's not able to do so. He's not militarily strong enough. So he ends up taking the province of Kabul, establishing himself there. And from Kabul, he looks into the region of South Asia as a potential area to conquer. And in that, he's following Timur because Timur had sacked
莫卧儿王朝的建立者巴布尔，是费尔干纳公国的统治者。费尔干纳谷地主要位于今天的乌兹别克斯坦。他是帖木儿帝国一系列帖木儿王子中的一员，也就是伟大的帖木儿帝国。他的后代都在中亚地区争夺权力。巴布尔带着重建帖木儿伟大帝国的想法离开了费尔干纳。但他没能做到。他的军事实力不够强大。所以他最终占领了喀布尔省，并在那里站稳了脚跟。从喀布尔出发，他将目光投向了南亚地区，将其视为潜在的征服地。在这方面，他是在追随帖木儿，因为帖木儿曾洗劫过
the Delhi Sultanate in 1398. And so he has this idea in his mind that he can create a new empire for himself in that region. So just to be clear, he is descended from Genghis Khan, the greatest conqueror in history, and from Timur, who maybe to people who are familiar with Elizabethan literature is better known as Tamburlain, the archetype of the great conqueror. So they have an absolute track record of going out and conquering places. And as I understand it, Babur wins his great victory that establishes himself in North India, outside Delhi. And then he goes on and he wins a battle at a place called Kanwar in 1527, which is outside the city of Agra, which is where in due course the Taj Mahal will come to be built. Does Agra have a kind of significance for the Mughals as a result of that, or is that
1398年的德里苏丹国。所以他心中有一个想法，那就是可以在那个地区为自己建立一个新的帝国。所以明确一下，他是成吉思汗（历史上最伟大的征服者）和帖木儿（对于熟悉伊丽莎白时代文学的人来说，他可能更广为人知的名字是“帖木儿大帝”，即伟大征服者的原型）的后裔。所以他们有着外出征服领土的绝对记录。据我了解，巴布尔在德里郊外赢得了那场确立他北印度统治地位的伟大胜利。然后他继续前进，在1527年于阿格拉城外一个叫坎瓦尔的地方赢得了一场战役，而阿格拉正是后来泰姬陵建成的地方。阿格拉因此对莫卧儿人具有某种特殊意义吗？还是说那
just coincidence? That's just coincidence. Agra was already a very important city in the region. Delhi actually had been, it was the capital of the Delhi Sultanate, the Islamic rulers of the region prior to the Mughals. But Agra was an exceptionally important city. And when Babur conquers the region of North Hindustan, as they called it, he sets up his first capital actually at Agra. So it's all looking good for the Mughals. And then
只是巧合？那只是巧合。阿格拉在当时已经是该地区非常重要的城市。德里实际上曾是德里苏丹国的首都，也就是莫卧儿人之前该地区的伊斯兰统治者。但阿格拉是一座极其重要的城市。当巴布尔征服了他们所称的北印度斯坦地区时，他实际上是在阿格拉建立了他的第一个首都。所以这对莫卧儿人来说一切看起来都很顺利。然后
it slightly goes wrong, doesn't it, under his son who ends up in Persia, I think. Yes. Humayun, who is Babur's eldest son, when he inherits this new region, he's not as strong a figure as his father had been. He doesn't command the same loyalty as his father had done. And so there are contenders immediately trying to take this kingdom from him. He's run out of Delhi in 1540, spends 15 years wandering, trying to get aid, and ultimately ends up at the court of the Safavid Shah in Iran, and with his help is able to come back and retake what had been his kingdom. Does that introduce a Persian influence on the Mughal court? Absolutely. It helps to explain what will be done when they decide to build the Taj Mahal. Absolutely. So when Humayun is able to come back, in terms of the artistic production of the
在他的儿子身上情况稍微出了点差错，我想他最终去了波斯，对吗？是的。胡马雍是巴布尔的长子，当他继承这个新地区时，他不像他父亲那样是一位强大的统治者。他没有像他父亲那样拥有同样的号召力。因此，立刻就有竞争者试图从他手中夺走这个王国。他在1540年被赶出德里，流亡了15年，试图寻求援助，最终到达了伊朗萨法维王朝沙阿的宫廷，并在他的帮助下得以回来并夺回了他曾经的王国。这是否给莫卧儿宫廷引入了波斯影响？绝对是。这有助于解释当他们决定建造泰姬陵时会采取的做法。绝对是。所以当胡马雍能够回来时，在宫廷的艺术创作方面，
court, some of the best Safavid court artists come back with him, first to Kabul and then to Delhi, and others join him there. So in the area of painting, the Persian tradition is very strongly impacting what becomes Mughal. But in terms of architecture, Babur, having come out of Ferghana, trying to take Samarkand, he spent time there, he spent time in Herat, and his successors do as well. So they know what imperial Timurid architecture looks like and what it's meant to look like. And that also has a very strong impact in what becomes a Mughal style. So there's all this swirl of influences, Central Asia, there's Persia, there's Hindu architecture of India, there's the Muslim architecture of India.
一些最优秀的萨法维宫廷艺术家随他一起回来，先是到了喀布尔，然后到了德里，其他人也在那里加入了他的行列。因此在绘画领域，波斯传统对后来成为莫卧儿风格的东西产生了非常强烈的影响。但在建筑方面，巴布尔从费尔干纳出来，试图夺取撒马尔罕，他在那里待过，在赫拉特也待过，他的继任者们也是如此。所以他们知道帝国帖木儿建筑看起来是什么样子的，以及它应该是什么样子的。这对后来成为莫卧儿风格的东西也有非常强烈的影响。所以这里有各种影响的交织：中亚、波斯、印度的印度教建筑、印度的穆斯林建筑。
The Mughals established themselves as the rulers of this kind of great swirl of influences and kingdoms. So Hameon comes back, his son Akbar, he establishes himself much more securely. And then his son Jahangir, he's the ruler, but he's basically an alcoholic and an opium addict, isn't he? Is it unfair to describe him as that? Yes, he's the ruler, but he's basically an alcoholic and an opium addict, isn't he? Is it unfair to describe him as that? Yes, he is the ruler. He is addicted to opium. He is an alcoholic, but that doesn't take away from his role as emperor. He's gone down in history as one of these people who was completely ruled by his wife and he didn't do anything. He was just interested in pleasure. Spliffing up.
莫卧儿人将自己确立为这种巨大影响力和王国交汇处的统治者。所以胡马雍回来了，他的儿子阿克巴，他更稳固地确立了自己的统治。然后是他的儿子贾汉吉尔，他是统治者，但他基本上是个酒鬼和鸦片瘾君子，不是吗？这样描述他公平吗？是的，他是统治者，但他基本上是个酒鬼和鸦片瘾君子，不是吗？这样描述他公平吗？是的，他是统治者。他确实对鸦片上瘾。他是个酒鬼，但这并不影响他作为皇帝的角色。他在历史上被描述为那种完全被妻子统治、什么都不做的人。他只对享乐感兴趣。沉溺其中。
Yeah. But he's my favourite Mughal emperor. I think he's one of the most fascinating of them. But he was imperial. He was a proper ruler, despite his addiction to drink and to drugs. And he has a very impressive wife, doesn't he? He does, yes. Nur Jahan, his last and favourite wife. He marries her in 1612. She had previously been married and had a daughter from that first marriage. But after her first husband dies, she comes to the Mughal court and is an attendant on one of the elder royal ladies. And so Jahangir meets her, falls deeply in love with her, and they get married. And she's a very important, politically influential woman.
是的。但他是我最喜欢的莫卧儿皇帝。我认为他是最迷人的人之一。但他确实是帝王。尽管他有酗酒和吸毒的瘾，但他是一位真正的统治者。他有一位非常令人印象深刻的妻子，不是吗？是的，确实。努尔·贾汉，他最后也是最宠爱的妻子。他在1612年娶了她。她之前结过婚，并从那次婚姻中生了一个女儿。但在她的第一任丈夫去世后，她来到莫卧儿宫廷，成为一位年长皇室女性的侍从。于是贾汉吉尔遇见了她，深深地爱上了她，他们结婚了。她是一位非常有政治影响力的女性。
And so this is important for the story of the Taj Mahal because Jahangir's son, Shah Jahan, the man who will build the Taj Mahal, succeeds Jahangir. And his favorite wife is Nur Jahan's niece. Is that right? I mean, this is all very kind of game of thrones. It's a little bit incestuous, yeah. Yes. So Shah Jahan, before he's titled Shah Jahan, Prince Khurram, he's betrothed to Arjuman Banu Begum, who is Nur Jahan's niece. And that betrothal takes place in 1605. So actually before Nur Jahan is even at the court, because Nur Jahan's father is in the upper echelons of the court hierarchy and her brother as well. So they're already an important family in the Mughal court administration. Her father's effectively Jahangir. He becomes effectively his prime minister. And these
这对泰姬陵的故事很重要，因为贾汉吉尔的儿子沙贾汗，也就是后来建造泰姬陵的人，继承了贾汉吉尔。而他最宠爱的妻子是努尔·贾汉的侄女。是这样吗？我的意思是，这听起来很像《权力的游戏》。这有点近亲通婚，是的。是的。所以沙贾汗，在被封为沙贾汗之前，即库拉姆王子，他与努尔·贾汉的侄女阿朱曼·巴努·贝古姆订婚，那次订婚发生在1605年。实际上是在努尔·贾汉进入宫廷之前，因为努尔·贾汉的父亲在宫廷等级制度中处于高层，她的兄弟也是。所以他们已经是莫卧儿宫廷行政中一个重要的家族。她的父亲实际上是贾汉吉尔的重臣。他实际上成为了他的首相。而这些
marriages then between the royal family and this Khorasani family, they make the linkages between them even stronger. So the marriage between Khurram and Arjuman Banu Begum, who's then titled Mumtaz Mahal, that happens in 1612 and Nur Jahan and Jahangir are married in 1611. So can you give us some sense of the personality of Shah Jahan? So he's more of an orthodox Muslim than his father, I think? He is. He's a more orthodox figure. He doesn't touch alcohol until he's basically forced to by his father on his, I think it's his 24th birthday. Jahangir kind of makes him, you know, take a drink. So no, he is a more orthodox figure, but he's not a fundamentalist. And this turn towards,
皇室家族与这个呼罗珊家族之间的联姻，使他们之间的联系更加紧密。所以库拉姆和阿朱曼·巴努·贝古姆（后来被封为泰姬·玛哈尔）之间的婚姻发生在1612年，而努尔·贾汉和贾汉吉尔在1611年结婚。那么你能给我们讲讲沙贾汗的性格吗？我想他比他父亲更像一个正统的穆斯林？是的。他是一个更正统的人物。他直到24岁生日时被父亲强迫，才开始接触酒精。贾汉吉尔算是强迫他喝了一杯。所以不，他是一个更正统的人物，但他不是原教旨主义者。这种转向，
his internal turn towards orthodoxy, it's actually really interesting. It doesn't very much affect, you know, how he rules, his concept of rule. And in fact, two of his children end up as practicing Sufis, and that's very tolerated and supported. So yeah, he is a more orthodox figure. And so he's a great warrior, and his wife comes with him on campaign. Is that normal? I mean, is that standard behavior, or is that unusual? It was more on the unusual side. I mean, the Mughal court was peripatetic, so it moved around. It was never stationary for very extended periods of time.
他内在向正统的转变，实际上非常有趣。它并没有很大程度上影响他的统治方式和统治理念。事实上，他的两个孩子最终成为了修行苏菲派的人，这得到了极大的宽容和支持。所以是的，他是一个更正统的人物。他是一位伟大的战士，他的妻子随他一起出征。这正常吗？我的意思是，这是标准行为，还是不寻常的？这更多是不寻常的一面。我的意思是，莫卧儿宫廷是巡回的，所以它会四处移动。它从未在很长一段时间内保持静止。
And the harem did move around with the emperor as well. But for Mumtaz Mahal to accompany Shah Jahan on all his military campaigns and everywhere he went. That was unusual. There was very much a deep connection between the two of them. So Mumtaz Mahal, this is the name that is given to his wife, and that means select of the palace, is that right? Yeah, the chosen one of the palace, yes. And is it, I mean, am I being too overly romantic if I ask, was she incredibly beautiful? I mean, what did she have that made him so devoted to her, that made him want to take
后宫也确实随皇帝一起移动。但泰姬·玛哈尔陪同沙贾汗参加他所有的军事战役，无论他去哪里。这很不寻常。他们两人之间确实有着深厚的联系。所以泰姬·玛哈尔，这是给他的妻子的名字，意思是“宫廷的精选”，对吗？是的，“宫廷的宠儿”，是的。我的意思是，如果我问她是否非常漂亮，我是不是太浪漫了？我的意思是，她有什么特质让他如此深爱她，让他想要带
her with him? I mean, she gave him 14 children. So there must have been quite a bond between them. There was this, an incredibly deep bond between them for sure. And yes, she had 14 children, seven of whom survived to adulthood. The connection between them, what was it based on? It's impossible to say because what we're told about her in the court histories, which are all written by Shah Jahan's court historians, it obviously her beauty is extolled, the kindness of her personality is extolled, her loyalty is extolled.
她一起去？我的意思是，她为他生了14个孩子。所以他们之间一定有很深的羁绊。他们之间确实有着极其深厚的羁绊。是的，她生了14个孩子，其中7个活到了成年。他们之间的联系是基于什么？这很难说，因为宫廷史书（全部由沙贾汗的宫廷史官撰写）中关于她的记载，显然极力赞美了她的美貌、她性格的善良、她的忠诚。
She must have been beautiful, but that's not enough, right, to form the kind of bond that they had. And, you know, so yeah, it's impossible for me to say, but one of the things actually, just on that, if I can quote one of his court historians. We're talking about a Muslim dynasty, you're talking about words written down for posterity. And one of Shah Jahan's court historians, when he's talking about actually the two of them, he writes that the mutual affection and harmony between the two had reached a degree never seen between a husband and wife among the classes of rulers or among the other people. And this was not merely out of sexual passion. The excellent qualities, pleasing habits, outward and inward virtues, and physical and
她一定很美，但这还不够，对吧，无法形成他们那样的羁绊？所以，是的，我无法断言，但关于这一点，如果我可以引用他的一位宫廷史官的话。我们谈论的是一个穆斯林王朝，谈论的是为后世写下的文字。沙贾汗的一位宫廷史官在谈到他们两人时写道，两人之间的相互爱慕与和谐达到了统治阶级或其他人群中夫妻间从未见过的程度。这不仅仅是出于性欲。双方卓越的品质、令人愉悦的习惯、内在与外在的美德，以及身体与
spiritual compatibility on both sides caused great love and affection. That's written by this court historian, Kazvini. This is written with Shah Jahan's permission because all of his histories, he approved what was being written in them. And to write about them in that fashion is really out of the ordinary. It's really remarkable that this idea of the bond is extolled to such a high degree that there obviously was great sexual chemistry that's extolled in these court histories. So all of it speaks to, in a way, this exceptional nature of the relationship between them. And Shah Jahan did have two other official wives who he consummated the marriages. He had a child with the third wife, but it was Mumtaz Mahal who
精神上的契合，造就了伟大的爱与深情。这是由宫廷史官卡兹维尼写下的。这是在沙贾汗的许可下写成的，因为他所有的历史记录，他都批准了其中的内容。以这种方式描写他们确实非同寻常。这种羁绊被赞美到如此高的程度，确实非常了不起，显然这些宫廷史书中也赞美了他们之间伟大的性吸引力。所以这一切在某种程度上都说明了他们之间关系的特殊性。沙贾汗确实还有另外两位正式妻子，他与她们圆了房。他与第三位妻子有一个孩子，但泰姬·玛哈尔才是那个
got him, who had his time and his love and his devotion. So it's reasonable to talk about this as a genuine love story. It is. It is genuinely a love story, for sure. She then dies while he's on campaign in the Deccan in Southern India. Yes. On the 17th of June, 1631, while giving birth to their 14th child. And the scale of his grief, I mean, firstly, his grief is something genuine and it is felt by one and all that the scale of his grief is something exceptional, is it? Yes. Again, from the histories, we are told that for a week he withdrew from the court and was in solitary mourning. And this is remarkable because the court activities under Shah Jahan achieved a very kind of rigid formulation. There were certain ceremonial activities which took place on a daily basis where he showed himself to the public, to his court. He was present. To
拥有他的时间、他的爱和他的奉献的人。所以称其为一段真正的爱情故事是合理的。是的。这确实是一个真正的爱情故事。后来他在印度南部德干地区出征时，她去世了。是的。1631年6月17日，在生下他们的第14个孩子时。他悲痛的程度，我的意思是，首先，他的悲痛是真实的，每个人都能感受到，他悲痛的程度是非同寻常的，对吗？是的。同样，根据史料，我们被告知他退出了宫廷，进行了为期一周的独自哀悼。这很了不起，因为沙贾汗统治下的宫廷活动已经达到了一种非常僵化的形式。每天都有某些仪式活动，他会向公众、向他的宫廷展示自己。他会出席。为了
take himself out of that and to go away for a week, it was an out of the ordinary circumstance. And we're told that when he did come out after that week, he wore white, which is the color of mourning in Islam. He wore white for a period of time. His eyesight got so bad from the amount of tears he shed, he had to start wearing spectacles. Within a few years, his beard had gone completely white. So there was a very strong emotional reaction to her loss. And it led to the creation of this incredible monument that we're talking about today. So she had obviously not died in Agra, but she'd been born there, right? Is that why he decides to take her body back to Agra?
让自己从那种状态中抽离出来，离开一周，这是一种非同寻常的情况。我们被告知，当他在那一周后出来时，他穿上了白色，这是伊斯兰教中哀悼的颜色。他穿了一段时间的白色。由于流泪过多，他的视力变得很差，不得不开始戴眼镜。几年之内，他的胡子完全变白了。所以他对她的离去有着非常强烈的心理反应。这导致了我们今天所谈论的这座不可思议的纪念碑的诞生。所以她显然不是在阿格拉去世的，但她是在那里出生的，对吧？这就是他决定把她的遗体带回阿格拉的原因吗？
No. At the time, Agra was the most important of the imperial capitals. So Agra, Delhi, and Lahore, up until about 1643, they are the three primary imperial capitals of the Mughal Empire. Under Akbar, Feth-e-Pursikri is also one for a period of time. So the capital city moved between these different cities. And Agra, at the time of Mumtaz Mahal's death, was where it was settled. And so, you know, that was one of the reasons. But then also, very quickly, the concept of the Taj Mahal takes place.
不。当时，阿格拉是帝国首都中最重要的一座。所以阿格拉、德里和拉合尔，直到1643年左右，它们是莫卧儿帝国的三大主要帝国首都。在阿克巴统治下，法泰赫普尔西克里也曾有一段时间是首都。所以首都城市在这些不同的城市之间移动。而在泰姬·玛哈尔去世时，阿格拉是定都之地。所以，你知道，这是原因之一。但随后，泰姬陵的概念很快就形成了。
And the space that was needed for what was intended, the location. You couldn't have had that idea of the space of the Taj constructed in Delhi. It could have been Lahore, but Lahore was the least important and also a bit more out of the central area of the empire. So Agra had the location as well as the status. This is what, I mean, this is a huge question. It's the obvious question. What is distinctive about the Taj Mahal and to what extent is it the expression of the entire culture of the Mughal empire and core? That is a huge question, Tom. Yeah, it is. I'm sorry. So what is important about the Taj Mahal. It is the culmination of the Mughal aesthetic of architecture. It is the zenith of the classical style of Mughal architecture. It is also layered with symbolism.
而且所需要的空间，预期的用途，位置。你不可能在德里建造泰姬陵那种空间概念。可能是拉合尔，但拉合尔是最不重要的，而且离帝国的中心区域也稍微远一点。所以阿格拉既有位置，也有地位。这是一个巨大的问题，这是显而易见的问题。泰姬陵有什么独特之处？它在多大程度上是莫卧儿帝国和宫廷整个文化的表达？这是一个巨大的问题，汤姆。是的，确实。我很抱歉。那么泰姬陵的重要性是什么？它是莫卧儿建筑美学的巅峰。它是莫卧儿建筑古典风格的极致。它也充满了象征意义。
So the commemorative aspect of Mumtaz Mahal. But it's equally a monument built to commemorate Shah Jahan. There's layers of political symbolism associated with the monument as well. It's the epitome of the idea of Mughal funerary architecture being representative of paradise um paradise in the quran so there's layers of paradisical symbol symbolism associated with it as well and it has stood as a monument that has captivated all who've seen it um so it is this i, grand expression of a Mughal building design. One of the other layers of symbolism as well is it's also speaking to the dynastic legacy of the Mughals, because the architecture of the Taj Mahal draws very heavily on Humayun's mausoleum in Delhi, which draws very heavily on Timurid antecedents in Central Asia. So it's speaking to this long dynastic line and the political legitimacy of the line. So there's so many different layers of symbolism tied up in this monument. And so it takes 22 years to complete,
所以，这是对泰姬·玛哈尔的纪念。但它同样也是为纪念沙贾汗而建的纪念碑。与这座纪念碑相关的政治象征意义也有很多层次。它是莫卧儿丧葬建筑代表天堂（古兰经中的天堂）这一理念的缩影，所以它也与天堂的象征意义相关联。它作为一座纪念碑，吸引了所有见过它的人。所以它是莫卧儿建筑设计的宏伟表达。另一种象征意义是，它也在诉说着莫卧儿王朝的遗产，因为泰姬陵的建筑在很大程度上借鉴了德里的胡马雍陵，而胡马雍陵又在很大程度上借鉴了中亚的帖木儿先例。所以它在诉说着这条漫长的王朝血脉和该血脉的政治合法性。所以这座纪念碑中蕴含着许多不同层次的象征意义。所以它花了22年才完成，
is that right? And involves a thousand elephants bringing in materials from across the world. Or is that all Orientalist exoticizing? Slightly exaggerated. The construction of the actual mausoleum, the white structure, is four years, 1632 to 1636. And the entirety of the complex, because the whole thing is planned as one unit. Because there are gardens, aren't there? Well, there's the mausoleum, the garden, a forecourt, a commercial space, and then another garden across the river. So the full complex is completed by 1643. So what is that? 11 years
是这样吗？并且动用了上千头大象从世界各地运送材料？还是说那全是东方主义的异国情调化？稍微有点夸张。陵墓主体，即白色建筑的建造时间是四年，1632年到1636年。而整个建筑群，因为整个东西是作为一个单元规划的。因为有花园，不是吗？嗯，有陵墓、花园、前庭、商业空间，然后河对岸还有另一个花园。所以整个建筑群在1643年完成。所以那是多少？11年
is what it took to build the full complex. At the time that it's being built, is it obvious that this is something in a different league from previous mausoleums that have been built, previous tombs? Or is this, at the time, is it perceived as being part of a long tradition, the standard thing that you do, all of this kind of stuff? Both, actually, Dominic, because it's in the tradition of monumental built funerary structures by the Mughals. We only have four monumental imperial tombs, and the Taj Mahal is the culmination of those, but it only ends up being an imperial tomb because Shah Jahan
是建造整个建筑群所花费的时间。在它建造的时候，显而易见它与之前建造的陵墓相比处于不同的级别吗？还是说在当时，它被视为长期传统的一部分，是你所做的标准事情，所有这类东西？实际上两者都有，多米尼克，因为它属于莫卧儿人建造纪念性丧葬建筑的传统。我们只有四座纪念性的帝国陵墓，而泰姬陵是这些陵墓的巅峰，但它最终成为帝国陵墓只是因为沙贾汗
is later buried there. One of the things to remember is that this is the zenith of this tradition, but it's built for a queen. And in that aspect, there is a tradition of funerary monuments built for the queens, the empresses, but this is on a different scale for a female mausoleum. It surpasses the monumental emperor's tombs that were built before it, the three that came earlier. And it is just this expression of perfection and refinement encapsulated in the structure. But that is because of that double commemorative aspect, commemorating Mumtaz Mahal, but equally and more importantly, commemorating Shah Jahan as this perfect king of this perfect kingdom.
后来被埋葬在那里。要记住的一点是，这是这一传统的巅峰，但它是为一位王后建造的。在这方面，确实有为王后、皇后建造丧葬纪念碑的传统，但这是女性陵墓中规模不同的一个。它超越了在它之前建造的纪念性皇帝陵墓，即早期的那三座。它只是封装在结构中的完美和精致的表达。但这正是因为那种双重纪念意义，既纪念泰姬·玛哈尔，同样也更重要地纪念沙贾汗作为这个完美王国的完美国王。
Can I just ask you, so on the outer face of the southern gate that leads into the gardens, there's some verses from the Quran, O thou soul which art at rest, return to thy Lord, pleased and pleasing him. Enter thou among my servants, and enter thou my paradise. So it's a very devoutly Muslim expression of piety, of the yearning, I guess, to be reunited in the afterlife. But I'm just wondering, is that seen by contemporary Muslim opinion as being a little bit excessive, this huge monument, or is it seen as being an expression of piety? So the use of Quranic phrases like that, it is an expression of piety. I mean, there's 22 verses
我可以问一下吗，在通往花园的南门外立面上，有一些《古兰经》的经文：“你这安宁的灵魂，回到你的主那里去吧，你既是喜悦的，又是被喜悦的。进入我的仆人行列，进入我的天堂吧。”所以这是一种非常虔诚的穆斯林虔诚表达，我想，是对在来世团聚的渴望。但我只是想知道，当代穆斯林舆论是否认为这有点过分，这座巨大的纪念碑，还是说它被视为虔诚的表达？所以使用像那样的《古兰经》短语，这是一种虔诚的表达。我的意思是，有22节
of the Quran on the structures of the complex, the tomb and the gateway. Partly because of precedence, there is a longer tradition of associating Mughal funerary gardens with the gardens of paradise. And this is across the Islamic world as well, but the Mughals take it to a different level. And these particular Quranic phrases, which are saying, as a believer, you enter the gardens of paradise, it has, again, double symbolism. It's not only about the religious duty of Muslims. It's about the idea that you are walking into an earthly representation of the gardens of paradise. And there's that association very strongly created with the use of these inscriptions at the Taj Mah paradise. And there's that association very strongly created with the use of these inscriptions at the Taj Mahal, but there's a precedence also at
《古兰经》经文刻在建筑群的结构上，即陵墓和门楼。部分原因是先例，将莫卧儿丧葬花园与天堂花园联系起来有着更长的传统。这在整个伊斯兰世界也是如此，但莫卧儿人将其提升到了一个新的水平。而这些特定的《古兰经》短语，即作为信徒，你进入天堂花园，它再次具有双重象征意义。它不仅是关于穆斯林的宗教义务。它是关于你正走进天堂花园的世俗表现这一理念。而且通过在泰姬陵使用这些铭文，这种关联被非常强烈地创造出来。天堂。而且通过在泰姬陵使用这些铭文，这种关联被非常强烈地创造出来，但先例也存在于
Akbar's Mausoleum in Secandra, which is outside of Agra, where the same kind of idea is presented. Brilliant. Okay, let's take a break now. We'll come back after the break and we'll continue talking about the architecture and history of the Taj Mahal and the ways in which it has been perceived over the centuries. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
阿格拉郊外的阿克巴陵墓，那里也呈现了同样的理念。太棒了。好吧，我们现在休息一下。休息后回来，我们将继续讨论泰姬陵的建筑和历史，以及几个世纪以来人们对它的看法。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐就是如此》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We're talking about the Taj Mahal with our guest Maureen Chida Razvi. And Maureen, we haven't actually discussed what the Taj Mahal means. Do we know what the name means? It means the crown of the palace. It's not how the Mughals themselves refer to the monument. In their writings, they refer to it as the Aluminum Tomb, but it was a contemporary name because we know it's referenced in certain European sources. It appears to be a corruption of Mumtaz Mahal's name being applied to the building. Right. And is it true that all the architects and the craftsmen were executed when they'd finished it so that they couldn't ever build again?
欢迎回到《历史就是如此》。我们正在与我们的嘉宾梅琳·奇达·拉兹维讨论泰姬陵。梅琳，我们还没有真正讨论过泰姬陵意味着什么。我们知道这个名字的意思吗？它意味着“宫廷的冠冕”。这不是莫卧儿人自己称呼这座纪念碑的方式。在他们的著作中，他们称之为“光辉陵墓”，但这是一个当代名称，因为我们知道它在某些欧洲文献中被提及。它似乎是泰姬·玛哈尔名字的变体，被应用到了这座建筑上。对。那么，所有的建筑师和工匠在完工后都被处决，这样他们就不能再建造其他建筑，这是真的吗？
That's Arabian Nights. Or is that, as I suspect, another Orientalist fantasy? That is very much an Orientalist fantasy, Dominic. The craftsmen and the architects and the supervisors are entirely too valuable for something like that to happen. And this is an idea which gets applied to many buildings, famous buildings throughout history. But there is this idea that the Oriental despot figure does this kind of thing on a regular basis. But there is this idea that the oriental despot figure does this kind of thing on a regular basis. But no, that's not true at all. But the fact you have stories like that being spread by Europeans, the fact that they have their own name for the Taj Mahal and the name that the building comes to get, suggests that this is a building that is seen by foreigners as well as by the people in the Mughal Empire as being an exceptional structure.
那是《一千零一夜》。还是说，正如我所怀疑的那样，这是另一种东方主义幻想？那在很大程度上是东方主义幻想，多米尼克。工匠、建筑师和监督人员的价值太高了，不可能发生那种事。这是一个被应用到历史上许多著名建筑上的想法。但确实存在这种想法，即东方专制君主会经常做这种事。但确实存在这种想法，即东方专制君主会经常做这种事。但不是，那根本不是真的。但欧洲人传播这种故事的事实，他们有自己的泰姬陵名称，以及这座建筑最终获得的名字，都表明这是一座被外国人以及莫卧儿帝国人民视为非凡结构的建筑。
And I would love to ask more about how European contemporaries, when the Azataj Mahal is being built and in the aftermath, but just before we come to that, could we just finish off the story of Shah Jahan, which is actually, I mean, it's tragic enough, he's lost his beloved wife, but it then goes even worse, doesn't it? It does, yes. Shah Jahan falls ill in 1657, and quite ill. There's a fear that he's not going to survive. Now, he has four sons, and one of them, the eldest, Dara Shukoh, had been designated the heir apparent. So he is the one who has planned to succeed his father. And he's the kind of Justin Trudeau, the Jacinda Ardern. He's kind of liberal, he's multicultural, all that kind of thing. Yes, yes. Liberal, multicultural. He's a
我很想多问一些关于欧洲同时代人在泰姬陵建造时以及之后的情况，但在我们谈到那个之前，我们能先结束沙贾汗的故事吗？这实际上，我的意思是，这已经足够悲剧了，他失去了他深爱的妻子，但后来情况变得更糟了，不是吗？是的，确实。沙贾汗在1657年病倒了，病得很重。人们担心他挺不过去。现在，他有四个儿子，其中长子达拉·舒科被指定为王储。所以他是那个计划继承他父亲的人。他有点像贾斯廷·特鲁多，像杰辛达·阿德恩。他有点自由派，多元文化，所有那一类东西。是的，是的。自由派，多元文化。他是一个
practicing Sufi and he has been raised and brought up with the intention. He was Shah Jahan's favorite, that he will be the next emperor. But when Shah Jahan falls ill, a war of succession breaks out. The other brothers, the other three decide they're not on board with Dara Shukoh becoming the next ruler. And so they start to gather their own forces and they make alliances between the three of them, Shah Shuja, Aurangzeb and Murad Bakhsh. They make alliances between them to get Dara Shako out of the picture. And Aurangzeb, the third son, he's being very sneaky, let's say. He's telling his other brothers, I'm not interested in being on the throne. I will help you get there.
修行苏菲派的人，他从小就被培养，意图让他成为下一任皇帝。他是沙贾汗的最爱。但当沙贾汗病倒时，继承战争爆发了。其他兄弟，另外三个决定他们不同意达拉·舒科成为下一任统治者。所以他们开始聚集自己的力量，并在他们三人之间结成联盟，沙·舒贾、奥朗则布和穆拉德·巴赫什。他们在他们之间结盟，要把达拉·舒科踢出局。而第三个儿子奥朗则布，他表现得非常狡猾，我们这么说吧。他告诉他的其他兄弟，我对王位不感兴趣。我会帮助你们到达那里。
I will help you militarily because Aurangzeb was a great military mind. And together, we'll work together to make sure Dara Shako doesn't get on the throne. So even after Shah Jahan gets better, he's very ill for about a month. And then he gets better, he's very ill for about a month, and then he gets better. But by then, the wars between the brothers have already started. It's kind of too late to pull back. And what ultimately happens is that Aurangzeb becomes the victor in this war. With his brother's help, he is able to have Dar es Sik captured and Dara Shako is then executed.
我会从军事上帮助你们，因为奥朗则布是一位伟大的军事天才。我们一起努力，确保达拉·舒科坐不上王位。所以即使在沙贾汗好转之后，他病了大约一个月。然后他好转了，他病了大约一个月，然后他好转了。但到那时，兄弟之间的战争已经开始了。想要撤回已经太晚了。最终发生的是奥朗则布成为了这场战争的胜利者。在他兄弟的帮助下，他得以俘虏了达拉·舒科，随后达拉·舒科被处决。
And kind of humiliated, isn't it? He's led through the streets of Delhi in chains. Yeah. Yeah. There's the idea that, you know, you want to project this person who up until this point is adored and loved and it's known he's intended to be the next emperor. And so to publicly humiliate him in a fashion is all part of this idea of then breaking down the myth of Dara Shukoh. Because Aurangzeb has a very clear idea that he's the next one on the throne. And he needs to make sure that he's the one who commands the respect of the people. So yeah, he then backstabs his other brothers and claims the throne for himself, imprisons Shah Jahan in the fort in Agra, where for the next eight years he lives in the confines of the palace.
而且有点羞辱，不是吗？他被戴着镣铐带过德里的街道。是的。是的。有一种想法是，你知道，你想投射这个直到此刻还被崇拜和爱戴的人，而且众所周知他注定是下一任皇帝。所以以这种方式公开羞辱他，都是打破达拉·舒科神话这一理念的一部分。因为奥朗则布非常清楚他自己是下一个坐上王位的人。他需要确保自己是那个能赢得人民尊重的人。所以是的，他随后背刺了他的其他兄弟，并为自己夺取了王位，将沙贾汗囚禁在阿格拉的堡垒中，在那里他接下来的八年生活在宫廷的禁锢中。
But then when he dies, Arangzeb has him buried in the Taj Mahal next to his mother. Yes. So when Shah Jahan dies, his body is taken by river. So one of the other children, Jahanara, who was hand in glove with Dara Shukoh, she's also imprisoned in the Agra Fort with her father. And actually after Mumtaz Mahal's death, she was the first lady of the empire. She had the status of queen, even though she was a princess. So her intention after Shah Jahan dies is that there will be grand processions, you know, through the streets to honor him as his body is taken to the Taj. But instead, it's taken at night by river to the mausoleum and buried there without
但当他去世时，奥朗则布让他被埋葬在泰姬陵，就在他母亲旁边。是的。所以当沙贾汗去世时，他的遗体是通过河流运送的。所以另一个孩子，贾汉阿拉，她与达拉·舒科关系密切，她也被囚禁在阿格拉堡与她父亲在一起。实际上在泰姬·玛哈尔去世后，她是帝国的第一夫人。她拥有皇后的地位，尽管她是一位公主。所以她在沙贾汗去世后的意图是，会有盛大的游行，你知道，穿过街道来纪念他，因为他的遗体被送往泰姬陵。但相反，它是在夜间通过河流被送往陵墓，并在那里被埋葬，没有任何
really any pomp and ceremony. And It's not until Aurangzeb himself comes to Agra, I think roughly a month after Shah Jahan dies, that any kind of grand celebrations of mourning happen. But they happen now with Aurangzeb as the emperor, without any kind of question about that because his father's now dead. And what about the story that comes from a French jeweler called Baptiste Tavernier, who visited India in the middle of the 17th century. And he says that Shah Jahan had plans to build his own tomb on the other side of the river, but these were interrupted by the war. And Aurangzeb basically scrapped that idea and shoved him in the Taj Mahal. So how much truth is there in that?
真正的排场和仪式。直到奥朗则布本人来到阿格拉，我想大约在沙贾汗去世一个月后，才发生了任何形式的盛大哀悼庆祝活动。但它们现在是在奥朗则布作为皇帝的情况下发生的，没有任何关于此的疑问，因为他的父亲现在已经去世了。那么关于那位名叫巴蒂斯特·塔韦尼耶的法国珠宝商的故事呢？他曾在17世纪中期访问过印度。他说沙贾汗有计划在河对岸建造他自己的陵墓，但这些计划被战争打断了。而奥朗则布基本上废除了那个想法，把他塞进了泰姬陵。所以这其中有多少真实性？
Archaeologically, there isn't any. And historically, from the Mughal perspective, there isn't any proof for this happening. I mean, Shah Jahan was an incredible architectural patron. And his histories are full of his different building projects and lots of kind of detailed information about them. It's how we know so much about the history of construction of the Taj Mahal. And there's no mention whatsoever of him planning a mausoleum for himself. It's entirely possible he would have done so had he not been deposed by his son.
从考古学上讲，没有任何真实性。从莫卧儿的角度来看，历史上也没有任何证据证明这一点。我的意思是，沙贾汗是一位了不起的建筑赞助人。他的历史记录中充满了各种建筑项目，以及关于它们的许多详细信息。这就是为什么我们对泰姬陵的建造历史了解如此之多。而且根本没有提到他计划为自己建造陵墓。如果他没有被他的儿子废黜，他完全有可能这样做。
But up until that point, there had not been any indication that he was planning to build his own tomb. So Tavernier is the first to mention this idea. And it's just, as you said, it's just a very brief few lines, right? There's nothing about material. There's nothing about it being a replica of the Taj. So those are ideas which come about later. And they were given further credence by the fact that, you know, I mentioned this was one huge complex that was built and there was a garden across the river. So that's the Metabagh, the moonlight garden. And it was created as a viewing area for the Taj Mahal because you then get this incredible
但在那之前，没有任何迹象表明他计划建造自己的陵墓。所以塔韦尼耶是第一个提到这个想法的人。正如你所说，这只是非常简短的几行，对吧？没有任何关于材料的内容，没有任何关于它是泰姬陵复制品的内容。所以这些想法是后来才出现的。而且由于我提到的这是一个建造的巨大建筑群，并且河对岸有一个花园，这些想法得到了进一步的信任。那就是月光花园。它被创建为泰姬陵的观赏区，因为你可以获得这种不可思议的
view of the monument reflected in the river. And you're in a garden and you're able to like see that. And, you know, by the moonlight, the idea. And there's an octagonal tank, water tank in the middle of that garden. So when that was unearthed, it kind of made people think, oh, these are the foundations of the octagonal Taj Mahal that Shah Jahan intended. But that's not the case. They weren't foundations,
纪念碑在河中倒影的景色。你身处花园中，能够看到那个。而且，你知道，在月光下，这个想法。那个花园中间有一个八角形的水箱。所以当那个被挖掘出来时，它让人们认为，哦，这些是沙贾汗打算建造的八角形泰姬陵的地基。但事实并非如此。它们不是地基，
it was just a water tank. So it's a lovely idea that he was intending a black Taj for himself, immediately opposite the Taj Mahal, but there's no proof of that. But it is fascinating how, as said at the beginning, that it's not just people at Shah Jahan's court who recognize the power of it, that it is Europeans as well. So there's another Frenchman, there seem to be a lot of Frenchmen at this time, François Bernier, who is a physician. And he's writing this as it's being constructed, that this monument deserves much more to be numbered among the wonders of the world than the pyramids of Egypt. So that's an incredible thing to say about a building
那只是个水箱。所以，他打算在泰姬陵对面为自己建造一座黑色泰姬陵，这确实是一个美好的想法，但并没有证据支持。但令人着迷的是，正如开头所说，不仅沙贾汗宫廷的人认识到了它的力量，欧洲人也同样如此。还有另一位法国人，当时似乎有很多法国人，弗朗索瓦·贝尔尼埃，他是一位医生。他在建筑建造时写道，这座纪念碑比埃及金字塔更值得被列为世界奇迹之一。对于一座建筑来说，这真是不可思议的评价。
as it's being constructed. And to what extent do you think the global fame of the Taj Mahal owes to foreign admiration? I mean, there's often the kind of tendency that foreigners admire things more than people who live in the country. Do you think that that foreign admiration was there right from the start? It does appear that it was there from the start because we have accounts like Bernier's and Tavernier's. And they're speaking to how incredibly striking and beautiful this monument. And as you say, like saying it's up there with the great pyramids. What's really interesting is that we have records, contemporary records of Europeans who are visiting and who are proclaiming about the beauty of the site and the magnificence of the site. And one of them, he's been in the empire and he writes about
在它建造的时候。你认为泰姬陵的全球声誉在多大程度上归功于外国人的赞赏？我的意思是，通常有一种倾向，即外国人比当地人更欣赏某些事物。你认为这种外国人的赞赏从一开始就存在吗？看起来确实从一开始就存在，因为我们有像贝尔尼埃和塔韦尼耶这样的记录。他们都在谈论这座纪念碑是多么令人惊叹和美丽。正如你所说，把它与伟大的金字塔相提并论。真正有趣的是，我们有同时代的欧洲人访问并赞美该地点的美丽和宏伟的记录。其中一个人，他曾在帝国境内，他写道
how it's one of the most beautiful buildings he's ever seen. But then he kind of questions himself and he's like, oh, is this because I've become used to the local aesthetic and maybe it's just in my head? And it's not until a visitor comes and proclaims about the beauty and the immense singularity of the Taj Mahal that he's like, okay, it is as beautiful as I think. Yeah. So lots of French people going on about how wonderful it is. The British capture Agro in 1803. It's now under their control. There is one apocryphal story that one of the viceroys, I think it was Lord William Bentinck, was planning to demolish it and auction off the marble, but apparently that's an absolute calumny. He was no Lord Elgin. But the viceroy who really becomes obsessed by it and does a great deal to preserve it is Lord Curzon, Dominic, who we had on our episode about domestic servants because he wanted to open a window, didn't he?
它是他见过的最美丽的建筑之一。但随后他开始怀疑自己，心想，哦，这是因为我已经习惯了当地的审美，还是这只是我的错觉？直到一位游客到来并赞美泰姬陵的美丽和无与伦比的独特性时，他才觉得，好吧，它确实像我想象的那样美丽。是的。所以很多法国人都在谈论它有多么美妙。英国人在1803年占领了阿格拉。它现在处于他们的控制之下。有一个杜撰的故事说，其中一位总督，我想是威廉·本廷克勋爵，曾计划拆除它并拍卖大理石，但显然这完全是诽谤。他可不是埃尔金勋爵。但真正对它着迷并为保护它做了大量工作的是寇松勋爵，多米尼克，我们在关于家仆的那一集中提到过他，因为他想开一扇窗户，不是吗？
And there was no servant and he couldn't open the window. So he threw a log through the pane of glass. Well, Curzon was the kind of epitome of um edwardian british auteur i suppose so he's uh ethan and baliel there's a famous verse that follows him around from his time at oxford my name is george nathaniel curzon i'm a most superior person my cheek is pink my hair is sleek i dine at blenheim once a week and um when he comes in as viceroy so this is the i think he came in in 1899 and maherin he he really appreciates the Taj Mahal, doesn't he? I mean, Curzon takes it very seriously. He does.
当时没有仆人，他打不开窗户。于是他把一根木头扔过了玻璃窗。嗯，寇松可以说是爱德华时代英国权贵的缩影，我想是的，他是伊顿公学和贝利奥尔学院的学生，在牛津时有一首著名的诗跟着他：我的名字是乔治·纳撒尼尔·寇松，我是最卓越的人，我的脸颊粉红，我的头发光滑，我每周在布伦海姆吃一次饭。当他担任总督时，我想他是1899年上任的，莫琳，他真的很欣赏泰姬陵，不是吗？我的意思是，寇松非常认真地对待它。他确实如此。
He is the first to kind of take, in a way, to kind of take ownership and responsibility for the monument in terms of wanting to set forward a series of, you know, projects to conserve the monument, to restore the monument, to take care of it in a proper way that it hasn't been taken care of for a while. Because there is a concept in Islamic societies, the concept of waqf, which is an endowment deed, which is written for every construction. And the Waqf for the Taj Mahal designated money for its upkeep and for the payment of the attendance and that kind of thing. And that existed until 1803 when the British stopped the Waqf. And so the upkeep of the Taj had started to decrease in the very early 19th century. So when Curzon comes, he recognizes it as a site which needs to be protected,
他是第一个在某种程度上承担起对这座纪念碑的所有权和责任的人，他想要提出一系列项目来保护、修复这座纪念碑，并以一种长期以来未曾有过的方式妥善照料它。因为在伊斯兰社会中有一个概念，即“瓦克夫”（Waqf），这是一种为每项建筑而写的捐赠契约。泰姬陵的瓦克夫指定了用于其维护和支付服务人员费用的资金。这种情况一直持续到1803年英国人停止了瓦克夫。因此，泰姬陵的维护在19世纪初开始减少。所以当寇松到来时，他认识到这是一个需要保护的地方，
which needs to be conserved. And he puts a lot of effort into that. I think it was something like, he puts 40,000 rupees in a single year toward its conservation. And in the previous 20 years or something, it had been just a fraction of that. So he really ups the amount of money which goes towards its upkeep. And he commissions this kind of great lamp from lampmakers in Egypt to hang in the Taj, which is still there today. He's quite a mogul figure, isn't he? I mean, he obviously quite fancied himself as the heir of the moguls ruling India. But there's also a sense in which into the 20th century, right the way up to independence, the Taj is quite an influence on the way that the British start designing their imperial structures, say the Victorian Memorial in Calcutta, and then Edward Lutyens' designs for buildings in New Delhi.
需要被保护。他为此投入了大量精力。我想他一年内投入了大约4万卢比用于其保护。而在之前的20年左右，这只是其中的一小部分。所以他确实增加了用于其维护的资金。他从埃及的灯具制造商那里订购了一盏大灯挂在泰姬陵里，至今仍在那里。他真是一个莫卧儿式的人物，不是吗？我的意思是，他显然很自以为是莫卧儿统治印度的继承人。但某种程度上，进入20世纪，一直到独立，泰姬陵对英国人开始设计其帝国建筑的方式产生了相当大的影响，比如加尔各答的维多利亚纪念堂，以及埃德温·鲁琴斯为新德里设计的建筑。
Do you think that the Taj has an influence on that? I don't know if I would say the Taj itself, but certainly Mughal architecture, the style of Mughal architecture, the concept of their buildings, because that point, Tom, it brings up the political power of architecture. You're creating structures which are visual stamps of rulership and ownership, you know, on land. And the Mughal tradition of architecture is one which just projects imperial power, right, and strength. And so when the British are now in a ruling position and are creating their own structures, they're drawing very heavily on the Mughal tradition of architecture. And you end up with this, I hate the term, but quote unquote, Indo-Saracenic style of architecture, which is kind of a British version,
你认为泰姬陵对那有影响吗？我不知道我是否会说是泰姬陵本身，但肯定是莫卧儿建筑，莫卧儿建筑的风格，他们建筑的概念，因为在那一点上，汤姆，它提出了建筑的政治力量。你正在创造作为统治和所有权视觉印记的结构，你知道，在土地上。莫卧儿建筑传统是一种仅仅投射帝国力量和强度的传统。所以当英国人现在处于统治地位并创造他们自己的结构时，他们非常依赖莫卧儿建筑传统。你最终得到了这种，我讨厌这个词，但所谓的“印度-撒拉逊”建筑风格，这是一种英国版本，
but drawing very heavily on the Mughal tradition because of the symbolic associations of it. And because the British take, because they value the building, during the Second World War, it's covered in scaffolding, isn't it, to protect it from Japanese bombing. And again, obviously that happens again in the wars between India and Pakistan in the late 1960s, early 1970s. Yeah, absolutely. again in the wars between India and Pakistan in the late 1960s, early 1970s. But when India becomes independent in 1947, the status of the Taj Mahal as a Muslim building means that it has an unusual position, doesn't it? In kind of Indian iconography, it's the most famous Indian building.
但由于其象征意义，非常依赖莫卧儿传统。而且因为英国人重视这座建筑，在第二次世界大战期间，它被脚手架覆盖，不是吗，以保护它免受日本的轰炸。同样，这显然在1960年代末、1970年代初印度和巴基斯坦之间的战争中再次发生。是的，绝对是。在1960年代末、1970年代初印度和巴基斯坦之间的战争中再次发生。但是当印度在1947年独立时，泰姬陵作为一座穆斯林建筑的地位意味着它处于一种不同寻常的位置，不是吗？在某种印度肖像学中，它是最著名的印度建筑。
It's a symbol of India abroad, but it's obviously not a Hindu building. ingrained in Indian history. You wouldn't have had the modern country of India without this Muslim history that they're currently so eager to deny. And so at partition, the Taj becomes this symbol of this new country, but it's because it's considered a symbol of India. The fact that it's a Muslim structure doesn't really play into its symbolic association with the country at that point. It's just a symbol of the incredible historical power of the region of which the Mughals were embedded in. But has that, you hinted that it has, has that changed in recent years? In very recent history, there's been a great push by the current BJP government to... So that's a kind of Hindu majoritarian government?
它是印度在国外的象征，但它显然不是一座印度教建筑。根植于印度历史。如果没有这段他们目前如此急于否认的穆斯林历史，就不会有现代的印度国家。因此在印巴分治时，泰姬陵成为了这个新国家的象征，但这是因为它被认为是印度的象征。它是一座穆斯林结构的事实在那时并没有真正影响它与该国的象征性联系。它只是该地区令人难以置信的历史力量的象征，莫卧儿人就植根于其中。但正如你所暗示的那样，这种情况近年来有所改变吗？在非常近期的历史中，现任印度人民党政府一直在大力推动……所以那是一个印度教多数派政府？
Yeah, it's a Hindu majority government, but they promote a very specific ideology, ideology of Hindutva, which places the Hindu past of India on a platform which is meant to crush the other pasts of the country. So including Islam? Including the Muslim past. I don't think it's too strong to say that. And one of the ways that they've gone about doing this is to actually try to erase the Muslim history of the region. So the most famous building in India, internationally, I mean, I read that Taj Mahal is apparently the most popular name for Indian restaurants in Britain. That's a measure of its fame abroad. What do you do with a building that famous? One way, it seems, is I was reading up on
是的，这是一个印度教多数派政府，但他们推行一种非常具体的意识形态，即“印度教性”（Hindutva）意识形态，它将印度的印度教过去置于一个旨在压制该国其他过去的平台上。包括伊斯兰教？包括穆斯林过去。我不认为这样说太严重。他们采取的方法之一是试图抹去该地区的穆斯林历史。所以印度最著名的建筑，在国际上，我的意思是，我读到泰姬陵显然是英国印度餐馆最受欢迎的名字。这是它在国外声誉的衡量标准。你如何处理一座如此著名的建筑？看起来，一种方法是，我当时正在阅读关于
this, that there've been a number of court cases, one of which got taken to the Indian High Court, another to the Allahabad High Court, claiming that actually it was originally a Hindu palace, which seems implausible, and in both cases was thrown out. So that obviously hasn't worked. No, it hasn't worked. But what's really frightening is that the court cases have proceeded to that extreme level where the idea... So let me back up a little bit. So these court cases, which have been undertaken, they've been undertaken by BJP leadership in order to have the Taj Mahal proclaimed a Hindu structure.
这一点，已经有了一些法律案件，其中一个被提交到印度高等法院，另一个提交到阿拉哈巴德高等法院，声称它实际上最初是一座印度教宫殿，这似乎难以置信，而且在两起案件中都被驳回了。所以这显然没有奏效。不，它没有奏效。但真正令人恐惧的是，这些法律案件已经进行到了那种极端的程度，以至于这个想法……让我退后一点。所以这些已经进行的法律案件，是由印度人民党领导层进行的，目的是让泰姬陵被宣布为一座印度教结构。
Because in their non-factual version of history, this was a Hindu temple dedicated to Lord Shiva built in the 12th century, and that it was stolen by Shah Jahan and turned into the Taj Mahal. And this is complete fabrication. Yeah, fantasy, fabrication. I was trying to think of the nice term to use. And what's really frightening is that you have government bodies which are pushing this new version of history. So the court case that you were, one of the ones you referred to, Tom, the one last year that went to the Allahabad court, there was a petition filed by one of the BJP leaders to have, there's chambers in the platform of the Taj Mahal, and there was a court case to have them opened because he was claiming that there were idols of Hindu gods in those rooms, and that they
因为在他们非事实的历史版本中，这是一座建于12世纪供奉湿婆神的印度教寺庙，并且它被沙贾汗窃取并变成了泰姬陵。这完全是捏造的。是的，幻想，捏造。我当时正试图想出一个好听的词来用。真正令人恐惧的是，你有政府机构正在推动这个新版本的历史。所以你提到的那些法律案件，汤姆，去年提交到阿拉哈巴德法院的那一个，有一位印度人民党领导人提交了一份请愿书，要求……泰姬陵的平台上有一些密室，有一个法律案件要求打开它们，因为他声称那些房间里有印度教神灵的偶像，而且它们
had been there since the construction of the monument and therefore proving it was a Hindu temple. And one of the supportive statements he made in this court case, or one of the statements he made to support this claim, came from the National Council of Educational Research and Training, which is the government body in India, which approves what goes into the history textbooks and that kind of thing. And that body said that there's no primary sources that exist to confirm Shah Jahan built the Taj Mahal, which is, again, complete fantasy. Because we've got the Mughal documents, we've got documents from the library and the archives of the Rajas of Ambar, who are the ones who sold the land to Shah Jahan. And then also we're supplying the marble for the construction.
自纪念碑建造以来就一直存在，因此证明它是一座印度教寺庙。他在这个法律案件中提出的支持性陈述之一，或者他为支持这一主张而提出的陈述之一，来自印度国家教育研究与培训委员会，这是印度的一个政府机构，负责批准历史教科书的内容等。该机构表示，没有任何原始资料可以证实沙贾汗建造了泰姬陵，这再次完全是幻想。因为我们有莫卧儿的文件，我们有安伯王公图书馆和档案馆的文件，他们是把土地卖给沙贾汗的人。而且当时还在为建筑供应大理石。
We have all the European sources, the contemporary sources speaking about what is happening at the time. And so it's really quite frightening that you have this entire mechanism underway at the moment to support the idea that this monument is not Muslim and that it was Hindu. And that actually has, it speaks to the incredible power of the visual, right? That you look at the structure, you think Mughal power, you think Shah Jahan, you think Manthaz Mahal. And what the BJP wants is to remove that association and give it a Hindu association. And the power of this monument was recognized, I mean, centuries ago. So in 1761, so this is post Aurangzeb, you're beginning to have the breakdown of centralized power in the Mughal court. And
我们有所有的欧洲资料，同时代的资料讲述了当时发生的事情。所以，目前有这样一个完整的机制在运作，以支持这座纪念碑不是穆斯林建筑而是印度教建筑的观点，这确实非常令人恐惧。这实际上说明了视觉的不可思议的力量，对吧？你看着这座结构，你会想到莫卧儿的力量，想到沙贾汗，想到蒙塔兹·玛哈尔。而印度人民党想要的是消除这种联系，并赋予它一种印度教的联系。这座纪念碑的力量在几个世纪前就被认可了。所以，在1761年，也就是奥朗则布之后，你开始看到莫卧儿宫廷中央权力的瓦解。而
one of the Hindu rajas takes the province of Agra in 1761. And one of his court priests suggests at that time, turning the Taj Mahal into a temple. So to make it a Hindu monument. So there's no idea being projected that it was Hindu, but there is the idea that we should claim it and take it away. I suppose in a way, it's a tribute to the incredible power and beauty of the Taj Mahal that all kinds of people want to claim it. Yeah, no, no, absolutely. I mean, it is. It speaks to its incredible importance. It speaks to its singularity. And to its romance. I mean, the romance of the story, I agree. It's so important to it. Whether it would be evident that it was a monument to love, if you didn't know the backstory, I'm not sure, but the backstory definitely adds to the
其中一位印度教王公在1761年占领了阿格拉省。他的一位宫廷祭司当时建议将泰姬陵变成一座寺庙。所以要把它变成一座印度教纪念碑。因此，并没有投射出它是印度教建筑的想法，但确实存在我们应该声称并夺走它的想法。我想在某种程度上，泰姬陵受到各种各样的人想要声称它，这是对其不可思议的力量和美丽的致敬。是的，不，不，绝对是。我的意思是，它是。它说明了它不可思议的重要性。它说明了它的独特性。以及它的浪漫。我的意思是，故事的浪漫，我同意。它对它来说太重要了。如果你不知道背景故事，它是否会明显是一座爱情纪念碑，我不确定，但背景故事绝对增加了
sense of wonder when you go to it. It definitely does. We went to store it on our honeymoon. So I'm very committed to the idea that it is a monument to love. No, no, it is for sure. And one of the, I don't know if you've come across this, but there is a, I don't know how far advanced it is, but there's a planned complex being built in Dubai, the Taj Arabia, which is centered around a replica of the Taj Mahal, except it's supposed to be three times larger. And it's being billed as the wedding destination of the world, replicating the quintessential monument to love. And on that hideous note, maybe we should thank you for guiding us around this most wonderful and beautiful and romantic of buildings.
当你去那里时的那种惊奇感。它确实如此。我们在蜜月时去过那里。所以我非常坚定地认为它是一座爱情纪念碑。不，不，它肯定是。而且其中一个，我不知道你是否遇到过这个，但有一个，我不知道它进展到了什么程度，但在迪拜有一个计划中的综合体正在建设中，即“阿拉伯泰姬陵”，它以泰姬陵的复制品为中心，只是它应该比原版大三倍。它被称为世界婚礼目的地，复制了典型的爱情纪念碑。带着这个可怕的音符，也许我们应该感谢你引导我们参观这座最美妙、最美丽、最浪漫的建筑。
Thank you, Maureen. No, thank you. It was my pleasure to be here. And thank you everyone for listening. and we'll be back very soon. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
谢谢你，莫琳。不，谢谢你。能在这里是我的荣幸。也谢谢大家的收听。我们很快就会回来。再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes,
我们共同主持《其余皆是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集，
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。